[Música]
qué decimos puse acusan de crímenes de
guerra Ucrania declara haber encontrado
cuatro cámaras de tortura en gerson tras
La retirada de las tropas rusas y la ONU
Investiga el presunto asesinato de
soldado rusos rendidos por parte del
ejército ucraniano analizamos en esta
edición
Andrés Manuel López Obrador suspende la
Cumbre del Pacífico en México porque el
congreso de Perú impide al presidente
Pedro Castillo salir del país la oea se
encuentra en territorio peruano para
investigar el conflicto entre el
legislativo y El Ejecutivo de Lima
Vladimir Putin recibió a Miguel Díaz
canel en Moscú el presidente de Rusia y
el de Cuba inauguraron un monumento a
Fidel Castro en la capital rusa el mismo
día en que Putin dio a conocer sus dos
nuevos rompehielos nucleares para
dominar el Ártico
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relativa a la guerra en Ucrania porque
el ejército de kiev declaró haber
encontrado cuatro cámaras de tortura en
la ciudad de gerson tras La retirada de
las fuerzas de Moscú Pero por otro lado
la ONU Investiga el asesinato por parte
de las fuerzas ucranianas de 10 soldados
rusos que se habrían rendido en lugansk
las autoridades de kiev tildan de
montaje las imágenes del crimen que sin
embargo Fueron verificadas por el New
York Times precisamente para ampliar la
información sobre estas acusaciones
mutuas de crímenes de guerra nos
acompaña Marta Moya en el estudio Marta
buenos días qué detalles da el New York
Times de estas acusaciones al ejército
ucraniano buenos días Rosa pues vamos a
comentar un artículo que sacó una
investigación visual de hecho que sacó
el New York Times el pasado domingo que
titula sugieren que soldados rusos
cautivos fueron asesinados a quemarropa
estos vídeos se hicieron virales en las
redes sociales durante la última semana
y se dan en la aldea de maquisca en la
región de lugares en el don vaso
recordemos al este de Ucrania donde las
tropas rusas han intentado forzar toda
su ofensiva allí estos bueno hace
referencia a una decena de soldados
rusos que habrían fallecido en manos de
los soldados ucranianos y ambos a partir
de este relato ambas partes del
conflicto se acusan de crímenes de
guerra por una parte Ucrania acusa a
Rusia de crímenes de guerra porque
durante la rendición de estos 10
soldados rusos uno de ellos habría
disparado a las fuerzas ucranianas y por
otra parte Rusia acusa a Ucrania de lo
mismo de crímenes de guerra porque
presuntamente
habrían disparado y los habrían
asesinado mientras estos soldados
estaban rindiendo y estaban indefensos
esto además se ha utilizado como un acto
de propaganda hasta los dos lados por
una parte Ucrania acusa a Rusia y elogia
las fuerzas armadas de Ucrania y por
otra parte Rusia acusa Ucrania de y esta
utiliza esta propaganda diciendo que
tienen que adelantar y tienen que hacer
más fuerte esa ofensiva y precisamente
la ONU también ha entrado a deprimir
esta cuestión no y así lo titula el país
que dice crece la presión sobre Ucrania
porque la ONU pide que quieras también
investigue estas acusaciones si Rosa y
además este artículo del país se divide
en dos partes no Por una parte como
decías no crece la presión sobre Ucrania
para esclarecer todo este hecho y por
otra parte dice que además Rusia sigue
liderando esta vulneración de Derechos
Humanos que solo en la región de gerson
donde las tropas rusas se retiraron hace
unas semanas se habían cometido hasta
500 vulneraciones de Derechos Humanos la
última esta que dábamos a conocer hace
escasos minutos No que se habrían
detectado cuatro cámaras de tortura en
la provincia de jerson donde ropa rusas
habrían torturado a militares y a
civiles ucranianos Además este artículo
del país dice que la ONU va a investigar
este asunto y Ucrania acusa de montaje a
Rusia porque los dice que los soldados
rusos no se han rendido de factos sino
que era todo una apariencia y Marta para
terminar con este repaso de la prensa
sobre estas investigaciones respecto a
potenciales crímenes de guerra en
Ucrania queremos cerrar con una
investigación de de Guardian que dice
habla del hallazgo de cuerpos de
soldados rusos quemados en gerson Sí y
eso es también es una exclusiva del
británico de Guardian que titula rusos
acusados de quemar cadáveres en un
vertedero en gerson esto se da a las
afueras de la ciudad de jerson donde se
hallaron banderas uniformes y cascos de
soldados rusos en una zona que se
convirtió casi en un lugar prohibido
durante la ocupación de las fuerzas
rusas en esta ciudad los residentes
contaron al periódico que allí los rusos
arrojaban cadáveres de hermanos caídos y
luego los incineraban estos estas
informaciones no se han podido verificar
de manera independiente pero los propios
periodistas de de Guardian que acudieron
al lugar cinco días después de La
retirada de las tropas rusas han podido
confirmar con residentes y trabajadores
de este vertedero la quema de los
cuerpos era la forma más fácil de
deshacerse de los cadáveres porque los
puentes del río nipro estaban muy
dañados y la infraestructura no podía
soportar el peso de los camiones para
trasladar a estos soldados y además para
terminar cita una llamada interceptada
soldados rusos que dice textualmente
simplemente los arrojan allí y luego es
más fácil hacer como si no hubieran
desaparecido Marta pues muchísimas
gracias para esclarecernos estas
investigaciones Seguiremos sin duda muy
pendientes de los hallazgos que se vayan
encontrando gracias
y precisamente las luchas geopolíticas
se expanden Más allá de la Guerra de
Ucrania Este martes el presidente de
Rusia Vladimir Putin inauguró dos barcos
rompehielos de propulsión nuclear con
los que pretende afianzar su liderazgo
en el Ártico para explotar los recursos
naturales y abrir rutas marítimas Luis
Muñoz con los detalles
el futuro pasa por el Ártico
especialmente para Rusia que este martes
inauguró dos nuevos barcos rompehielos
de propulsión nuclear el yakutia listo
para entrar en funcionamiento y el ural
que lo hará pronto
Los buques de una clase tan alta son de
importancia estratégica para nosotros
son necesarios para el estudio y
desarrollo del Ártico para garantizar
una navegación segura y sostenible en
esta región aumentando el tráfico a lo
largo de la ruta del mar del Norte en el
consejo del Ártico hay presencia de ocho
países Dinamarca Islandia Noruega Suecia
Finlandia Rusia Canadá y Estados Unidos
casi todos menos Rusia forman parte de
la otan Suecia y Finlandia han pedido
acceso al bloque se cree que en el
Ártico hay un 25% de reservas mundiales
de varios recursos naturales Mientras
que el deshielo causado por la crisis
climática podría abrir nuevas rutas
marítimas hasta dos más rápidas
con el derretimiento de la capa de hielo
ha habido una gran discusión entre los
estados árticos y no árticos sobre el
potencial económico todo desde el acceso
a los suministros de energía los metales
y minerales y hasta la apertura de
nuevas rutas de navegación
su control es estratégico y Moscú lleva
la delantera los analistas creen que
occidente necesita 10 años para ponerse
al día con el ejército ruso en la región
Rusia cuenta con infraestructura
portuaria desarrollo tecnológico y
extensión geográfica por lo que trata de
imponer sus propias reglas en la zona
desde antes de 2014 queríamos más
actividad aliada en el norte queríamos
que la otan vigilara también en el norte
tener una vista de 360 grados desde el
Ártico que la otan incluyera el Ártico
Entonces
desde 2005 Rusia reabierto decenas de
bases militares de la era soviética en
el Ártico donde tiene soberanía en más
de 24.000 kilómetros de Costa y el
presidente Vladimir Putin recibió en
Moscú a su homólogo cubano Miguel Díaz
canel quien lleva a cabo una gira
internacional que empezó en Argelia y lo
llevará también a Turquía y a China
entre otras cuestiones el gobierno de La
Habana expresó su intención de importar
hidrocarburos desde Rusia ambos
mandatarios inauguraron en la capital
rusa un monumento en honor a Fidel
Castro a quien Putin reconoció haber
establecido una amistad histórica con la
unión soviética además Putin aseguró que
el kremlin defiende la soberanía de Cuba
y denuncia el embargo de Estados Unidos
sobre la isla
Cuba cordera enérgicamente
las sanciones que hoy se imponen de
manera unilateral e injusta a la
federación de Rusia
las causas del conflicto actual en esta
zona hay que buscarlas en la política
agresiva de Estados Unidos y en la
expansión del otan hacia la fronteras de
Rusia lo que Cuba ha denunciado de
manera sistemática en foros
internacionales
Cuba como ha expresado en muchas
oportunidades se pronuncia por una
solución negociada al actual conflicto y
en Irán la central nuclear de Fort dog
está enriqueciendo uranio al 60%, 16
veces más que el umbral de 3,67
permitido en el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
del que Washington se retiró en 2018 a
la Hoya le preocupa que Teherán esté
cada vez más cerca de crear una bomba
nuclear
lejos de un consenso entre Terán y
occidente en la escalada nuclear sigue
en Irán Ahora hay una nueva central que
enriquecerá uranio al 60% la de fortdow
en las afueras de Teherán
como respuesta a la resolución de la
junta de gobernadores la organización de
la energía atómica de Irán ha
incrementado el uranio al 60% en la
central nuclear de fortdown Y es que la
ya tensa relación entre irangelo yea se
ha complicado después de que el
organismo decidiera respaldar una
resolución propuesta por Estados Unidos
a Francia Reino Unido y Alemania en la
que se exige facilitar explicaciones
técnicas creíbles después de descubrir
restos de uranio entre su ubicaciones a
no declaradas acusaciones que Teherán ha
rechazado ya tachado de anti iraníes Y
políticamente motivadas
cómo Irán ha señalado en repetidas
ocasiones la razón por la que las
negociaciones no han llegado a su fin y
las partes implicadas no pueden reanudar
el acuerdo nuclear es obviamente porque
Estados Unidos carece de voluntad
política
eran dispone de una reserva de entorno a
3673 kilogramos de uranio enriquecido en
diferentes purezas del 2%
un 20% y 60 por ciento frente al máximo
de 300 kilogramos y una pureza máxima de
3,67%, permitida bajo el acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 que Estados Unidos abandonó
unilateralmente bajo la administración
de Donald Trump en 2018 y que Irán dejó
de cumplir progresivamente eloía asegura
que Irán está solo a un pequeño paso
técnico para enriquecer uranio al 90%.
un umbral necesario para fabricar un
arma nuclear además Irán ya ha asegurado
que no piensa volver a las negociaciones
para revivir el acuerdo nuclear si
occidente no retira las acusaciones en
su contra el gobierno de ultraderecha de
Italia presentó los presupuestos para
2023 un plan económico que se espera que
sea aprobado por el congreso dado que la
coalición liderada por Georgia meloni
cuenta con mayoría en el legislativo
nuestra corresponsal en Roma Natalia
Mendoza con los detalles
35 mil millones de euros Este es el
gasto total del presupuesto para el año
2023 presentado Este martes por el
gobierno italiano un presupuesto que
prevé mayormente un gasto destinado a
ayudar familias y empresas con unos 21
mil millones de euros para limitar el
impacto de la inflación y del aumento
del precio de la energía el gobierno
italiano facilitará créditos Fiscales
que pasarán del 40 al 45% para las
empresas con mayor gasto energético se
destinarán 4.200 millones de euros a
reducir los impuestos de los
trabajadores también se anunció que el
IVA baja del 10 al 5% para todos los
productos de primera necesidad para la
primera infancia y los productos de
higiene femenina y para las familias con
escasos recursos económicos se usarán
500 millones de euros para bajar el
precio de una serie de productos de
primera necesidad Igualmente se añade un
mes más del permiso a las madres
trabajadoras después del parto que
pasará de ser retribuido del 30 al 80
por ciento otro capítulo importante las
pensiones se anunció un nuevo plan para
anticipar la jubilación que permitirá a
los italianos dejar de trabajar con 41
años de contribuciones y 62 años de edad
según estimaciones esta medida afectaría
a unas 50.000 personas aquí en Italia el
presidente mexicano Andrés Manuel López
Obrador confirmó la suspensión de la
Cumbre de la alianza del Pacífico la
razón es que el congreso de Perú impide
el viaje a México del presidente Pedro
castillo de hecho se contempla la
posibilidad de trasladar el encuentro a
territorio peruano iniciativa la que el
presidente peruano dio su respaldo y
precisamente a petición de Castillo la
oea está en el país para investigar la
crisis entre el poder ejecutivo y
legislativo
la Organización de Estados Americanos
llega a Perú representado por una misión
de alto nivel el organismo intenta
mediar en la crisis política que vive la
nación suramericana su primer día de
trabajo estuvo marcado por la reunión
con el presidente Pedro Castillo así
como con funcionarios de la fiscalía y
el congreso ninguna intención de parte
del
congreso de hacer un golpe
de estado respetuosos de la de la de la
Democracia eso fue algo que precisamos
firmemente por su parte el presidente
Castillo señaló según su punto de vista
las causas del problema algunos sectores
Quieren poner en peligro la democracia y
la estabilidad del país con mentiras
para golpear una gestión enfocada en
trabajar por el progreso e igualdad de
todos en este sentido la vicepresidenta
de la nación dime boluarte aseguró que
la democracia en el país estaba en grave
peligro mientras se celebraban los
encuentros manifestantes en favor y en
contra del gobierno protestaron en las
cercanías del Congreso
presidente que es un delincuente cómo es
posible que dentro de nuestro país
tengan que mangonear maltratar la imagen
de un presidente del Perú Perú pide una
crisis política que enfrenta al poder
ejecutivo con el judicial y el
legislativo
hasta aquí las noticias
[Música]